Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain an Indian psychological drama film
called “Taare Zameen Par.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
Ishaan is an eight-year-old imaginative kid,
widely known as a troublemaker among his mates.
He fails every subject and is the
lowest-ranking student in his classroom.
He is in his second year of third grade and by the
looks of his report card, he will have to repeat
the same grade again. In contrast to Ishaan,
his elder brother Yohaan is an ideal student.
Outside studies, he plays tennis and is competing
in the upcoming inter-state tennis championship.
Ishaan frequently gets into fights with the
neighborhood kids who bully him. One day,
a kid’s mother complains about Ishaan’s
behavior to his father Nandkishore. He has
to embarrassingly apologize to the kid and his
mother. After they leave, he shoves Ishaan to
the floor to discipline him. Although Nandkishore
loves his children, he is too harsh on Ishaan. He
believes that Ishaan’s low scores and inability
to do basic tasks are because of his laziness.
The next day at school, Ishaan’s English teacher
asks him to read a line from the book. He tries
his best but can hardly form a word. He has
difficulty in understanding the letters but the
teachers mistake it for him being a brat. When she
repeatedly urges him to read, he yells gibberish
and is sent out of the class. It is not a
new thing for Ishaan to be punished. In fact,
he spends most of his time outside rather than
studying because the teachers think of him as
a disturbance to the other students. That
day, Ishaan hadn't done his math homework.
To avoid facing the math teacher, he runs
away from school and spends the entire day
wandering around the neighborhood.
He enjoys the day to his fullest,
buying ice cream, spending time by the sea, and
analyzing the passersby. By the end of the day,
he returns to his school bus without
anyone noticing his absence. At home,
we see him make a beautiful painting. Ishaan
loves to paint and his imaginative mind helps
the cause resulting in over-the-top pieces.
Later, his mother Maya tries to tutor him and
make him do his homework. She notices that his
handwriting is awful and he can hardly spell
anything right. She associates his inability with
laziness and scolds him like everyone else.
The next day, Ishaan will have to provide his
teacher with an absent note from his parents.
Scared of getting in trouble, he begs
his brother to write the note for him.
Yohaan makes him promise he will never skip school
again and writes the note. The kid shows it to his
teacher who doesn’t question its authenticity.
He also pretends to cough to make it seem like
he was actually sick. That day, the math teacher
surprises the kids with a test. Ishaan is handed
the test paper but to him, the letters look like
they are dancing. The first question asks him
the multiplication of three with nine. In his
head, the kid imagines the third planet Earth,
and the ninth “planet” Pluto fighting each other.
He fantasizes about the Earth destroying Pluto and
rationalizes that the answer is three. Leaving
the rest of the questions blank, he submits the
test. When asked by his friends, he confidently
claims that he enjoyed the test thoroughly.
The next day, Nandkishore returns from a
business trip. Ishaan is overjoyed by his
father’s return and hugs him dearly. However,
during breakfast, Nandkishore finds the fake
absent note from the day before. On investigating,
he finds out about Ishaan running away from school
and wandering alone in the streets. The very next
day, the parents go to meet his teachers and the
principal who condemn his behavior in class. They
also find out about the recent math test and its
results. The principal assumes Ishaan is a special
child who needs to be sent to school for children
with disabilities. Nandkishore is horrified
at the thought of his son being disabled.
Both parents are worried about their kid’s future
so they decide to send him to a boarding school.
Ishaan is completely against the idea.
He rebels and cries, begging them to
keep him home and although the parents do
not want to be separated from him either,
they do what they think will be the best for him.
That night, Ishaan dreams of losing his mother in
a crowd and wakes up screaming. When she tries
to calm him down, he promises to study harder
if they let him be home. This breaks Maya’s heart
but Nandkishore is adamant about his decision.
The day finally comes when Ishaan is taken to
the boarding school in the countryside. He will
have to share a dorm with other children and will
only be allowed to meet his family once a month.
It is a nightmare for the eight-year-old who
has never been away from his home. The hostel
warden welcomes him by declaring that his old ways
won’t be tolerated here. After touring the school,
the family leaves with a heavy heart. Ishaan just
watches their car drive away with teary eyes.
He stays like that for several minutes even
after the car vanishes from his view.
When it starts to get dark, he walks inside the
hostel while still crying. He doesn’t talk to
anyone and hardly eats dinner. At night, when
he cannot sleep he goes to the bathroom and
cries quietly, missing his mother. Meanwhile, Maya
reaches home and goes through Ishaan’s belongings.
To her dismay, she finds a flipbook of him
being taken away from his family. The book
breaks her heart as she realizes how much
the kid dreads being away from them.
In the hostel, Ishaan struggles to do normal
things like tying his tie and shoelaces. On
his first day, the Hindi teacher Mr. Tiwari makes
him sit on the first bench with the class topper,
Rajan. The teachers soon realize that Ishaan
isn’t normal. He hardly pays attention in
class and is physically punished by his
art teacher. Nothing changes from how he
was in the previous school. He is always sent
outside the class as punishment and is excluded
from the class activity for ruining it.
With time, he gets so frustrated that he tears
his books apart and throws them into the bin.
He stops trying to do better in school and goes
into a spiral of depression and self-loathing.
When his parents come to meet him after a month,
he locks himself inside a room and bursts out
crying for the first time since he last saw them.
On being urged, he runs outside and takes
several laps of the basketball court to rebel.
The family takes him to a hotel for the night
to give him a break from his life at the hostel.
Yohaan gives him a hamper of painting supplies
as a gift but little does he know, Ishaan has
shut out his creative side and stopped painting
altogether. The next day, the family bids him
farewell and leaves him alone yet again.
Later that day, Ishaan is the lowest he has
ever been. He looks down from the terrace
of the school thinking about how it feels
to jump from that height. His only friend Rajan
interrupts his thoughts and tells him about their
new art teacher. Ishaan doesn’t think much of it
because no teacher has ever helped him. However,
it is surprising to the kids that the new teacher
Ram enters the class in a joker costume. He sings
a song, plays flute, makes them dance, and lets
them enjoy the class, in contrast to all other
teachers. While the old Ishaan would have loved
this, the depressed one doesn’t participate in any
of it. As their first task, the students are asked
to draw or paint anything they want. Ram wants
them to show their creative side so he knows what
he has to work on next. The children start to draw
several things, all different from one another’s,
but Ishaan doesn’t even touch the paper.
Initially, Ram assumes that the kid is taking
some time to think but even when the class ends,
Ishaan’s paper is blank. Worried, Ram asks
him what is wrong but doesn’t get a reply.
That evening, Maya calls to talk to Ishaan
but he only holds the phone to his ears and
doesn’t say anything. He is informed that they
will have to postpone the next visit by a week
because of Yohaan’s tennis competition. To Ishaan,
this only confirms that his family doesn’t care
about him. He sheds a single tear and walks away
without saying anything. The next day, Ram sees
Ishaan kneeling down outside the classroom.
Intrigued by his behavior, he asks Rajan about
him. Rajan reveals that Ishaan has difficulty
understanding letters no matter how hard he tries.
Ram teaches in a school for disabled children so
he has an eye for kids who are special. To find
out more about Ishaan, he goes through his old
notebooks and finds a pattern of similar mistakes.
Even while teaching the special children,
he cannot get the thought of Ishaan out of
his head. He used to have the same problem in his
childhood so he feels sympathetic to the kid.
Weeks later, he recognizes what Ishaan’s actual
problem is and travels to his hometown to meet
his parents. They welcome him and let him take
a look at Ishaan’s bedroom. Ram is surprised to
find out that Ishaan used to paint. This makes
him even sadder that the kid lost his sparkle
because of the pressure that was put
on him. Nandkishore belittles his son,
claiming that he is lazy and hates studying.
Ram retaliates and shows them the pattern in
Ishaan’s mistakes. He often inverts the letters
as if he has difficulty differentiating them.
Still, the father associates it with laziness
but Ram bluntly claims that he is wrong.
He declares Ishaan has a neurological condition
called dyslexia that causes him to not understand
certain patterns like letters and words. In
addition, he has difficulty coordinating which
causes him to not be able to tie his shoelace.
The kid must have been suffering so much because
no one understood that he couldn’t read
and assumed he was just being lazy.
Nandkishore thinks Ram is calling his son a retard
and lashes out at him. To make him understand,
Ram asks him to read foreign letters written
on a box. When Nandkishore is scolded for not
understanding the letters, he finally realizes
what his kid must be going through. Still,
he refuses to acknowledge that his son can make a
living out of his only passion; painting. Ram is
determined to prove him wrong. When he returns to
the school the next day, he teaches the kids about
all the famous historical figures who weren’t
so good at studying when they were children.
He gives them examples of scientists, actors, and
philosophers which makes Ishaan feel a lot better
about himself. When Ram asks them who invented
the light bulb, Ishaan speaks for the first time
in weeks and answers, Thomas Eddison. Ram sees a
shimmer of hope for the boy to learn. Later that
day, Ishaan is by the pond when he uses rubber
bands and leaves to make a working boat.
Ram is so impressed that he brings the structure
home and keeps it as a decoration. Ishaan’s
creative senses start to flow again but he still
has a long way to go before learning to study like
the other kids his age. One day, Ram goes to the
school’s principal and tells him about Ishaan’s
problem. The principal suggests they send him to
the school for children with special needs but
Ram is confident that Ishaan can study with the
regular kids. He suggests the teachers understand
the kid’s problem and help him accordingly.
When the principal says it is not possible,
Ram offers to teach Ishaan every day after school.
The principal allows it for the sake of the child.
Starting the next day, Ram uses various innovative
methods to help Ishaan differentiate letters of
the alphabet. They learn using sandboxes, play
dough, sensory methods, and so on. Ishaan also
takes help from audiobooks and stairs to
learn to calculate. In only two months,
he begins to understand the letters that the other
teachers couldn’t teach him in several years.
One day, Nandkishore comes to the school to talk
to Ram and boast about how they are researching
more about their son’s condition. He wants Ram
to know he is not an absent father and is proud
to be the way he is. Ram, on the other hand,
blames the father for being the reason the kid
lost self-confidence which even Nandkishore
cannot deny. On his way out, he sees Ishaan
trying to read from the notice board. Regretful
of unknowingly hurting his child, he tears up
and cannot get himself to face him.
A few days later, Ram organizes a painting
competition for both teachers and the students of
the school. Everyone gathers in the amphitheater
and participates. Ishaan uses the painting
supplies that he was gifted by his brother
for the first time. The competition starts and
everyone gets busy drawing. Even the teachers
enjoy the event and do their best. By the end of
it, Ishaan creates a beautiful painting of himself
sitting by the pond. He goes to the front to
submit the painting and sees that Ram has painted
a portrait of him. He is left speechless at the
sight. A while later, it is announced that the
winning painting will be on the front of the new
edition of their yearbook. The principal proclaims
that the decision was difficult because two
paintings stood out the most; Ram’s and Ishaan’s.
In the end, Ishaan is declared the winner while
the second prize goes to Ram. The crowd erupts
in cheers. For the first time in his life, Ishaan
feels recognized for his talent. He cannot help
but cry and runs to his teacher to hug him.
In the last scene, Maya and Nandkishore come
to the school for the end of the year
parent-teacher meeting. The principal
boasts about Ishaan’s talent showing them his
painting on the front of the school’s yearbook.
Unused to the new attention, the parents are left
shocked. The principal also praises Ram for doing
a great job teaching the kid in the way he
needed it. Later, the parents meet Ishaan’s
teachers who show them the report card and
compliment the kid’s undeniable progress.
Outside, the couple watches their son playing and
cry tears of happiness. Nandkishore thanks Ram for
helping Ishaan and apologizes for his behavior.
Lastly, Ishaan bids farewell to Ram and goes back
to his hometown for a vacation.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.